bonjour et bienvenue pour ce stop
science dédié à tous ceux qui n'ont pas
lu l'origine des espèces et qui le vit
bien
car cet épisode ne sera pas sur darwin
pas une seule leçon de biologie au
collège au lycée ou à l'université ne
commence en histoire de darwin de sa
théorie du voyage sur le beagle de son
escale aux galapagos dépassons et toussa
toussa
fichez la paix à darwin darwin avec
yahoo bien raison darwin manger tilbury
ou bien des pâtes et préférait-il le rap
ou le death metal darwin aurait-il été
charlie on s'en fiche il serait temps
pour les biologistes de couper le cordon
car messieurs dames les biologistes en
idolâtrant darwin vous créez une icône
qui vous fait passer pour des fanatiques
faisant au passage penser que la théorie
de l'évolution est basée uniquement sur
la pensée de darwin
or si darwin est à l'origine de l'un des
principaux piliers de la théorie de
l'évolution
à savoir l'hypothèse de la sélection
naturelle la biologie a fait quelques
nets progrès depuis notamment en matière
de paléontologie d'écologie et surtout
de génétique c'est bien les uns
discipline était totalement inexistante
à l'époque de darwin car la notion de
gêne était encore inconnu de plus placé
darwin au centre est à l'origine de
l'édifice évolutif c'est oublier combien
l'idée de l'évolution des espèces est
plus vieille que ça le grand père de
charles darwin erasmus darwin lui-même
et et évolutionniste bien avant son
petit fils sans oublier le français la
marque ou bien encore robert chambers
est bien entendu de nombreux savants de
l'époque médiévale qui au moyen-orient
et au maghreb ont eu l'intuition de
l'évolution des espèces
des centaines d'années avant darwin mais
c'est qui rendait la théorie de
l'évolution des espèces peu convaincante
à l'époque c'est le fait que personne ne
comprenait vraiment comment les espèces
faisait pour évoluer
darwin en découvrant le processus de la
sélection naturelle et à apporter une
réponse
la sélection naturelle c'est quoi au
juste ce n'est pas une force ni une
forme d'intelligence supérieure à la
nôtre non un rien de si fantaisiste
c'est juste une expression pour
qualifier un phénomène naturel de
sélection donc d'élimination non
aléatoire quel qu'il soit voici un
exemple simple dans un pays en guerre
plusieurs bateaux sont en vente à la
pêche un bombardement détruit la
majorité de la flotte
seuls les plus petits et les plus
silencieux des bateaux parvient
à se faufiler entre les bombes les
pêcheurs vont t'ils reconstruire leur
bateau exactement comme il est et non
ils vont construire des petits bateaux
sur le modèle de ceux qui reviennent les
petits bateaux se reproduise mais pas à
l'identique
exactement comme nous et à chaque
bombardement le processus recommence
rendant chaque nouvelle génération de
petit bateau plus petit et plus furtif
que la précédente
nos bateaux évolué c'est aussi simple
que ça la sélection naturelle rayonne
magique arrêt n surnaturel les êtres
vivants sont juste des petits bateaux
voguant sur l'océan tumultueux de
l'existence et seuls ceux qui arrivent à
bon port feront des petits
c'est ça l'idée de darwin mais darwin
n'a pas inventé l'évolution l'idée
d'évolution est né bien plus tôt que
cela à partir de la volonté de
classifier les espèces l'une des
classifications les plus anciennes et
les plus rudimentaires et celle
qu'aristote a appelé l'échelle des êtres
c'est une classification très simple au
demeurant et mes cailloux c'est moins
bien que les plantes est les plantes
c'est moins bien que les animaux et les
animaux abbas est moins bien que les
hommes
rigolez pas je suis sûr que vous vous
êtes déjà dit ça au moins une fois dans
votre vie
la simple observation de la nature entre
néanmoins que certain es tu ressembles à
mi chemin entre certaines de ces
catégories et gomme donc les frontières
entre les barreaux de l'échelle
ainsi les coraux et les éponges des
animaux vivants fixés sont à mi-chemin
entre les plantes et les animaux et les
singes sont à mi-chemin entre les
animaux et les hommes il n'en a pas
fallu plus pour que l'idée d'une
évolution d'une catégorie à une autre
germe dans l'esprit de heaven miss
kawaii grands savants perse qui vivait
presque mille ans avant darwin même
cuvier pourtant un fervent défenseur du
fixisme quand il dit aucune de ces
partis ne peut changer sans que les
autres changent aussi basse pour un
évolutionniste qui ne s'assume pas
darwin n'a pas une sorte d'illumination
miraculeuse sur le beagle
son idée est un pur produit des progrès
de la science de son époque une idée de
sélection naturelle aurait de toute
façon germées sans lui et oui car
quelque part à l'autre bout du monde
wallace découvrez lui aussi la sélection
naturelle et même s'il l'a présentée de
façon un peu moins brillante et
monumental que darwin
cela montre bien que l'idée était dans
l'air et enfin ne croyait pas que darwin
et travailler seul pendant toute sa vie
il a discuté avec son entourage avec des
scientifiques proche de lui et beaucoup
de gens
grands penseurs de son époque ont en
quelque sorte brainstorm et avec lui y
compris le redoutable et redouté cuvier
britannique
la pl câble génie de la paléontologie
victorienne la terreur des amphithéâtres
universitaire j'ai nommé le terrifiant
soeur richard owen
ah bah il a pas l'air redoutable et du
tout comme ça et puis d'ailleurs il
n'était pas contre darwin ricciardo mais
en fait il était pour l'évolution mais
contre la sélection naturelle
et puis cette image là elle fait
référence à l'espèce de paris ce géant
découverte par darwin en amérique du sud
lors de son voyage autour du monde et
que ricciardo wen a étudié à sa demande
et il l'a nommé milo dont darwini en son
honneur
alors c'est une sorte de rivalité
cordiale là c'est ça eh bien oui nul à
cesser toute sa vie durant d'écrire et
de réécrire de repenser sa théorie et de
l'éditer car oui même darwin peut se
tromper tout simplement parce que la
théorie darwinienne de l'évolution ce
n'est pas une religion c'est de la
science et la science sans cesse se
repenser l'évolution des espèces est
elle une idée complètement folle sorti
de l'esprit génial de darwin vous
l'aurez compris la réponse est non mais
penchons non plus avant sur cette
question les affirmations extraordinaire
applique des preuves plus qu'ordinaire
pour les étayer dit-on l'évolution
serait-elle ligne de ses lourds des
affirmations dans la charge serait
tellement énorme qu'aucune preuve ne
saurait l'a démontré la réponse loin de
se trouver profondément enterrés dans le
registre fossile ou de se trouver
uniquement accessible dans le plus
incompréhensible des grimoires de
biologie ne pouvant être déchiffrés que
par des rues 10 spécialistes se trouvant
dans les plus sombres arcanes de la plus
obscure aux bibliothèques universitaires
se trouve en fait juste sous votre nez
notre monde n'est pas fixe il est sans
cesse en mouvement les continents dérive
le niveau des mers monte et descend le
dessin de notaire varie les montagnes
croiser puis suze les rivières change du
lit le climat change et les espèces
céder place sachant que notre adn ne
restent pas fixe au fil des générations
comme en témoigne le simple fait que
vous êtes différent de vos parents
eux-mêmes différents de leurs parents
etc etc
car notre adn laissées suis aussi de
changer nous sommes tous mus temps c'est
pour cela que vous êtes unique
dès lors comment notre espèce pourrait
elle ne pas changer
quelle sorte de force incroyablement
puissante l'obligerait à rester fixe
alors que tout autour d'elle et à
l'intérieur
les volumes le fait que les espèces
change y compris la nôtre n'a rien
d'extraordinaire c'est une conséquence
logique des conditions physiques et
chimiques de notre environnement qui
varient tout le temps et ça ça n'a rien
à voir avec perrine c'était la logique
pure élémentaire le monde et comme à
tapis roulant et si vous ne courrez pas
à la même vitesse que lui il vous éjecte
sélection naturelle
l'hypothèse d'évolution sous-entendu de
changement sans direction particulière
n'est pas une hypothèse lourde
au contraire c'est soutenir la fixité du
monde et de notre espèce qui est une
affirmation lourde car elle va dans le
sens contraire de tout ce que nous
pouvons observer dire que les espèces ne
change pas c'est ça l'affirmation
extraordinaire car il faudrait alors
expliquer par quel moyen dans un monde
tout est en constante variations une
entité telle que notre espèce ou
n'importe quel autre ne changerait pas
mais attention à ne pas confondre
évolution et adaptation l'adaptation
c'est quand cette évolution prend une
direction particulière celle de la
survie de l'espèce
autrement dit quand une espèce ne
s'adaptent pas et disparaît
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que la nature à
l'air aussi parfaite elle n'autorise pas
l'existence d'espèces incapable
d'endurer son rythme effréné
nous sommes tous des produits de
l'adaptation de par le simple fait que
tout le monde ne survit pas la pollution
la cigarette et sans compter une
quantité de mutation horriblement
mutilante tue des milliers d'embryons
humains parfois sans même que leur mère
ne se rendent compte qu'elles sont
enceintes
nous ne soupçonnons même pas l'existence
de ce phénomène et en particulier le
nombre de ces mutations dégoûtante pour
la simple mais très bonne raison qu'elle
ne donne naissance à absolument rien si
ce n'est parfois un des spécimens eux
pour musée des horreurs et l'air de rien
c'est ça la sélection naturelle
seuls les survivants vivent assez
longtemps pour avoir une chance de se
reproduire et de donner naissance à
d'autres futures survivants peut-être
mais seulement s'ils survivent et
évidemment pour conclure pour que
l'évolution n'existe pas alors il
faudrait deux conditions primo que nous
soyons tous des clones les uns des
autres et que nous reproduisions par
clonage uniquement et deuxio il faudrait
que ledit processus de clonage se fasse
sans que la moindre petite mutation et
lieu hausse
infime soit elle c'est pas gagné c'est
même pour tout vous dire impossible
en tout cas ça n'existe ni dans la
nature ni en laboratoire et que darwin
et existe et nous on n'y changera rien
s'il n'avait pas existé
quelqu'un d'autre aurait découvert tout
ça à sa place car une fois les volets
sur la mise l'idée de la sélection
naturelle devient une évidence
c'est même si évident que plusieurs
scientifiques à la fois ils y ont pensé
en mettant darwin au centre vous fait
penser que la théorie de l'évolution des
espèces ne repose que sur un unique
piliers et les créationnistes adore ça
car ça leur en fait - à démolir mais de
nombreux domaines de la biologie se
tiennent les vos missions y compris
certains mandarine ne soupçonnait même
pas l'existence
tant et si bien qu'aujourd'hui vouloir
comprendre le monde qui nous entoure est
impossible sans comprendre les tenants
et les aboutissants de la théorie de
l'évolution car en ce monde
rien absolument rien dans aucun domaine
que ce soit de la biologie ou des
sciences naturelles n'a de sens à part à
la lumière de l'évolution des espèces
si cette option est terminé merci de
l'avoir si pour en savoir plus nous vous
conseillons la lecture de l'origine des
langues non non non non moi je la
recommande pas non non c'est juste un
invivable pavé sans image est vieux de
150 ans non si vous voulez vraiment
faire honneur à darwin lisez plutôt le
livre biologie évolutive écrit par des
chercheurs français et qui est une
synthèse de la nouvelle théorie
darwinienne de l'évolution revu et
corrigé
sorti en 2010 au moins vous serez plus à
jour qu'en lisant darwin directement
merci à tous